if you've seen thor ragnarok you may
think the movie left goddess of death
hello situation pretty clear-cut
UPK may be lovers it's Jan here and
before I go any further here's your
spoiler warning if you haven't seen
Ragnarok yet because today I want to
look at some of the clues in the film
together with Marvel's plans for Thanos
plus Heller's comic-book history to
theorize why there's a good chance we'll
see hella back in Avengers infinity war
or Avengers 4 and just to let you know
I've got a couple of Marvel giveaways
running at the moment so keep watching
this video for more details of how to
win let's start with the first clue that
hella could have survived that giant
sword strike from Sirte there's an
especially relevant moment earlier in
Thor Ragnarok that hints at Heller's
incredible power and near invincibility
after she arrives on Asgard she takes
out the Warriors 3 as well as a slew of
elite Asgardian fighters in an
incredible display of her skills at one
point though she gets stabbed in her
back all the way through to her front
with a sword
this kind of stabbing would be enough to
kill or at least severely wound any less
powerful character but Heller just
carries on fighting taking out all the
remaining soldiers it's a detail that
happens very quickly so you might not
have taken it in fully the first time
round but it demonstrates that what
would be deadly to many burly seems to
leave a scratch on Heller indicating she
has superhuman durability in the MCU as
she does in the comics and possibly even
regenerative powers interestingly VFX
supervisor Jake Morrison said that when
they designed Heller's costume the
scripts detailed that she had to get
stabbed in the suit and then the suit
had to heal around it and also her cape
had to absorb bullets on that point it's
worth noting that Heller is wearing her
cloak in this scene with Sirte which we
also know from the comics has an
important effect on her powers speaking
of Heller's powers when she revealed a
true history of Asgard beneath Odin's
mural you could see a painting that
showed she originally wielded mule near
and before that we also saw her shatter
Thor's mighty hammer which is Odin once
said was forged in the heart of a dying
star in other words hellas power is
incredible in Thor Ragnarok
and Thor realized that even he plus the
other Avengers could not defeat her okay
you say but a stabbed from an Asgardian
sword isn't the same as the absolutely
enormous sword that Surtur brought down
on how
and no it isn't but intriguingly at the
moment that Surtur brought his sawed
down on heller a bright oval-shaped
light surrounded her which seems a
little curious heller
like dr. strange has a power of
teleportation and can open portals to
instantaneously move to another part of
the universe she arrived in Norway in
that manner and if she was fast enough
she may have escaped sir - this way -
and again hella is still wearing her
cloak when she's struck by Sirte and if
you look really carefully it seems like
she could have been using her cloak to
shield herself against his attack on top
of that we never actually see a real
close-up of hellas apparent demise
likely because Marvel realized they have
a good villain here and therefore don't
want to lose her for good or they have
other plans for her already and I kinda
like the idea that hella either escaped
or that her powers are such that she
could have survived that takedown by
Sirte meaning that she's floating around
in space somewhere but let's just assume
for a moment that despite all those
powers the combination of Sirte sword
and then as God exploding was too much
and that hella did die well the thing is
of course these are comic-book movies so
if the Craters one - hella can be
brought back as has happened before in
the comics something else to consider is
the eternal flame which could be useful
in resurrecting hella if she is indeed
dead when Heller entered Odin's treasure
vault she referred to the eternal flame
as true power and she used it to
resurrect Fenris wolf and her undead
army plus Saoirse was resurrected with
the eternal flame in order to bring
about Ragnarok in the comics the eternal
flame can't be extinguished and with
Santos turning up on the sanctuary to
ship in the mid credit scene I wonder
whether he could have picked up the
eternal flame assuming it's still
burning together with haleh's body and
putting the two together we could get a
resurrected version of Heller or could
Thanos use the soul stone which some
fancy is being connected with the
eternal flame to bring Heller back to
life next we need to talk about the
Norse and why he's a big part of the
Reeves and Marvel may bring back Heller
I think we can look at these two
characters as soulmates of sorts
they're both megalomaniacs whose
ambition it is to conquer the universe
remember that in Thor Ragnarok Heller
revealed she was frustrated with Odin
when he decided to rein in as God's
Empire once
two of them at Concord the nine realms
in contrast her father hella wanted to
carry on and conquer the entire cosmos
bringing Heller and Thanos together then
would be a deadly combination as they'd
form perhaps the MC news most twisted
and lethal couple and it's worth noting
that Hallett and Thanos actually do get
together in marvel's current run of the
unworthy Thor comics now I can see that
Hallett and Thanos share a twisted view
of the universe but despite multiple
cameo appearances so far we still don't
know exactly why the NAS is collecting
the Infinity stones other than a
somewhat generic thirst for power
perhaps that's all it is but what if he
already has a connection with Heller I
mean we know that Odin kept hella
banished while he was alive but we don't
know if Thanos was aware of her ultimate
fate and her conquests alongside her
father before that but if he was it's
not inconceivable that he might have
felt a kinship with her and that he
would have wanted to gain enough power
to impress her or try to break her out
of prison and for the final piece of the
puzzle we need to go back to the
original source material earlier this
year when Kevin Feige was asked about
Thanos's motivation he wouldn't commit
to anything too specific but he did say
that Thanos's motives will be similar to
those he has in the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline in the comics to recap briefly
in the comics thanasis desire to wield
the Infinity Gauntlet is tied up with
his desire to impress the character
mistress death he adores and he uses the
gauntlet to obliterate half the
population in the universe for her and
if you think back to the mid credit
scene in the first Avengers film it
seems like this has already been hinted
at as at the end of that movie Thanos
responded with a smile when he was told
that to challenge humans would be to
court death the infinity war trailer at
d23 and comic-con showed the no
streaking large-scale destruction and I
wonder of his motivation is because he's
trying to prove himself to the goddess
of death Heller and to get payback for
what happened to her in Thor Ragnarok I
think Heller would be a great substitute
in the MCU for mistress death from the
comics as Heller is an interesting
character who's already been established
and that means that Marvel don't have to
introduce yes another character in the
third and fourth Avengers movies which
are already overflowing with characters
of course you may still be skeptical
about Hellas return and it may still be
that the supervillain really is dead and
gone for good
however when Marvel and Cate Blanchet
were asked about the possibility of hala
returning they were pretty coy marble
Studios producer Brad window bomb has
said that hella is one of the best
villains that Marvel has ever had and
has confirmed that she represents all
the things that Thanos values and Cate
Blanchet herself hasn't ruled out
returning to the MCU as hella either I
also wonder whether some scenes with
hala have already been filmed for either
Avengers infinity war or Avengers 4
afterall reshoots for thor ragnarok took
place in atlanta which is worth filming
for Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4
took place so it wouldn't have been too
hard to secretly film some scenes with
Kate Blanchet and Josh Brolin who plays
Thanos on a set with the reduced number
of crew perhaps a post-credits scene for
Avengers infinity war revealing that
Heller is actually still alive now that
would be an N credit scene to remember
so what do you think about heller
returning to the MCU would you like her
to team up with Thanos and infinity war
or Avengers 4 or do you have any other
theories on why Thanos is trying to
collect all the Infinity stones let me
know what you think in the comments
below and make sure you also subscribe
for a chance to win some cool marble
merch I'm giving away a thor ragnarok
Funko pop and also a very cool obsessed
with Marvel book by Titan books and I'll
be announcing the winners on my upcoming
Justice League videos if you enjoyed
this don't forget to hit the thumbs up
button and also check out some of my
other Thor Ragnarok videos on all the
movies deleted scenes plus more great
Theory videos by tapping the screen
right here thanks for watching and see
you next time
you became movie lovers
[Music]